the author is michael derda
thank
you coming up next book tv presents
afterwards an hour-long discussion
between a guest host and the author of a
new book
this week catherine olmsted professor of
history at the university of california
davis talks about her book real enemies
which looks at the role of conspiracy
theories in american history and
politics professor olmstead discusses
her book with university of southern
california sociology professor barry
glassner author of the culture of fear
why americans are afraid of the wrong
things
this interview was taped on the campus
of ucla during the 2009 los angeles
times festival of books
[Music]
i'm barry glassner i'm a professor of
sociology at the university of southern
california and the author of several
books including the culture of fear and
more recently the gospel of food it's my
great pleasure today to be in
conversation with professor catherine
olmstead she's a professor of history at
the university of california at davis
she's a specialist in political and
cultural history of the united states in
the 20th century she's also the author
of three books the first challenging the
secret government which is about the
investigations of the cia and the fbi
following watergate
second book titled red spy queen which
is a biography of elizabeth bentley
and her third book the book that we're
going to be discussing today
real enemies conspiracy theories and
american democracy world war 1 to 9 11.
so i'd like to begin with an incident
in your book
that i found particularly revealing
about
really the whole theme of the book and a
lot of what's been going on in the u.s
and this goes back to 1992
when bill clinton had been elected
president
uh and he
called in his longtime friend webster
hubble
and you recount how
he talked to his friend who he was
thinking of appointing planning to
appoint to a high position in the
administration
and he gave him a couple of secret
orders
so he asked him two questions that you
recall in the book
first was who killed jfk
and the second was are there ufos
now as i was reading this i was thinking
wow
how did we get to that point
in u.s history that this young
very bright very well educated
president
would essentially take so seriously a
couple of conspiracy theories
well that's why i included the incident
in the book because i think it's so
revealing that by 1992 we had gotten to
the point where the head of government
had conspiracy theories about the
government you know and so so what i
explore in the book exactly is how did
we get to this point that uh bill
clinton himself would think that there
was
perhaps some government involvement and
a cover-up of ufos or a cover-up in the
kennedy assassination and that there
were secret government files somewhere
that webb hubble you know now could put
his hands on um and that all it took was
access and then you could find out the
answers to these questions so conspiracy
theories about the government were
really permeating american culture by
the 1990s
so by that point they were really
quite common even even to the point that
a president would take them seriously so
let's go back you're a historian
let's let's go way back um and i also
found intriguing that in in your review
of u.s history in this regard that in
the 18th and 19th century
while conspiracy theories about the
government were not
non-existent they were pretty rare
but then you know even
even in the beginning of the 20th
century
they were pretty uncommon and then they
just took off right and so so what
changed well and and i guess i'm
interested in both parts why were they
so uncommon in the early days
well it's not that they were
non-existent in the early days but they
tended to focus on individuals so that
uh
well first of all there were a lot of
conspiracy theories about
minority groups
so that uh americans some americans
would have conspiracy theories about the
jews or the catholics or the masons or
the mormons and there was an emphasis on
religious or racial minorities there
were conspiracies about the government
but they tended to be
fears
that
there would be a cabal of individuals
who would
have
uh undue influence on in the colonial
era on the king and then in the
national period on the president
what begins to change in the 20th
century and especially after world war
one and that's why i start the book
there
is
americans start to have conspiracy
theories not just about individuals who
might take over the government but about
the government itself that it's not just
a fear that there might be malign people
in the government but that the state
itself
is a sinister force
and the reason is that before world war
one the u.s government was so small that
you know
it doesn't do that much but beginning in
world war one you have the emergence of
the modern state in the united states
and so you start having a government
that's big enough to
carry out conspiracies and that in fact
does sometimes carry out conspiracies
it's also a government that starts
having surveillance agencies which is a
first in american history during world
war one uh the government criminalizes
dissent with the espionage and sedition
act so it's against the law for
americans to criticize the government
and they start having secret agents go
around
and
arrest people who are making public
speeches and also intimidate
americans who are
viewed as unpatriotic so that
for example a bureau of investigation
agent might go up to someone and say
i hear that you were criticizing the war
effort you know that's against the law
do you want me to refer you to the
prosecutor or do you promise
not to do this anymore so there's
intimidation there's also prosecution
there's surveillance and so americans
start to to believe that the government
is surveilling them because it is and
they start to worry more about
government conspiracies from that moment
on
but then uh there were by the time that
we get to the 20s 1920s 1930s
i conspiracy theories have really kind
of
taken hold i mean they're they're
fairly common and
there's a fair amount of talk about them
and
i was struck by the fact that in your
book you show that really they had some
major effects
um isolationism
was among them right could you could you
talk a little bit about the kind of the
outcome of this yes well the conspiracy
theories about world war one were that
either arms manufacturers and or bankers
had tricked the united states into
joining the war
and these conspiracy theories are
particularly prevalent in the mid 1930s
so about 15 20 years after the war is
over
and as a result
many americans
believe that the united states should
never have gotten involved in the last
world war that they were deceived into
it that the united states had no um real
national interest in it and so this
conditions their response to the world
crisis of the 1930s so that they believe
since the last war was a mistake getting
into the next world war will also be a
mistake
so uh the theories about world war one
one really influenced the way americans
um
interpret the crisis crises in europe
and asia in the late 1930s
and then
following from that
i think you said even in in the book
even as recent as as late rather as 1941
right
britain is sort of standing alone
against hitler and
what was it 80 something percent of of
the country was still opposed to
american participation in the war is
that right yes and so how much of that
um
sentiment would you say had to do with
this kind of conspiratorial thinking and
and and sense of the of the recent
history i think a lot of it did because
um people believed that the united
states had gotten involved in the last
war because
there were financial interests
uh that wanted to support britain for
their own financial gain and so they
believed that this the second world war
was a replay of the last and they did
not um make allowance for the fact that
hitler was not the kaiser you know and
they saw um
they did not believe that the united
states had any national interest in
getting involved in world war ii so at
that point then
how were these conspiracy theories
spread among the population you know we
think now you know you go online they're
all over the internet how did they
spread at that in that period well of
course it's it's much more difficult um
uh in the i start the book in the world
war one period and there's there's a
famous free speech case from world war
one in which a group of anarchists who
believed that president wilson was
involved in a conspiracy uh both to get
the united states into world war one but
also to intervene in the in the
bolshevik revolution in russia decided
that they wanted to print up their
theories and so they wrote them up and
they they printed them on on a hand
operated printing press and they got a
bunch of leaflets and then they they
climbed to the top of the tallest
building they could find in midtown
manhattan and then they threw the
leaflets down yeah just literally
dropped them on the heads of um
the passersby uh you know one of whom
was a policeman and who turned them in
for violating the sedition act and so
they were put on trial um so this became
a famous free speech case but that's how
you got your your theories distributed
um in in 1918
um you know the internet is a really
tall building from which you can
throw lots of ideas so what i look at in
the book is is the evolution from from
then to now and
um so in the beginning of course it's
it's the print media and then it becomes
uh also spread through newspapers books
professors journalists congressmen
generally elites almost always male
elites are the ones uh spreading these
theories yeah let's talk about that for
a minute back at that period before we
move forward
so how important
was the established press at that point
you know the the
the the newspapers of the time the the
prominent newspapers at the time my
sense from from reading the book is that
they weren't very right um ever uh
terribly important in spreading
conspiracy theory theories is that right
or maybe a little more back then well it
depends there were certainly um some
newspapers that were identified with the
isolationist cause like the chicago
tribune
and so uh a columnist for the chicago
tribune and to a lesser extent columnist
for scripps howard uh did spread these
these theories um and then uh with the
second world war with the theories about
pearl harbor these theories um are also
spread by the newspapers on the extreme
right
so they really were pretty important but
from the start
meaning in the in the early fairly early
20th century it was really
male politicians who were particularly
influential right which has continued to
be the case
yes yes it is um there's also uh some
professors and journalists i spent a lot
of time looking at the at the papers of
a man named harry elmer barnes and he
was a professor and a newspaper
columnist very prolific and he
helped to spread the
theories about world war one that the
united states should not have gotten
involved that it was really about
bankers
and he also
even during world war ii became
convinced that that pearl harbor uh was
a conspiracy he was very
anti-interventionist in in world war ii
and so he was convinced from the
beginning that the attack on pearl
harbor was part of a roosevelt plot to
get the united states into a war that it
should not get into and so he
was influential in setting up a network
of academics and journalists and
increasingly elected officials as well
and how much did anti-semitism play into
that at that point
well it does play a role i think uh
certainly in uh the world war ii
theories um because some of the people
who early on believe that pearl harbor
was a conspiracy were motivated because
they thought the united states was
fighting the wrong enemy in world war ii
uh they believed that the united states
should not be fighting hitler it should
be fighting the soviet union and some of
them were anti-semitic
some of them quite overtly so some of
them less so but i think that certainly
played a role at the least
they were not too concerned about
hitler's policies towards the jews and
thought that was really none of
america's business
okay let me shift gears a little bit for
for a moment let's talk about the sort
of larger picture that that you paint
and then we'll get back to some of the
particular cases again
but
you know if i if i take your book as a
whole
it seems
to be the case that the u.s is
particularly prone to these kinds of
beliefs and conspiracy theories about
the government
and more broadly
um i've found in my own work that
americans tend to be pretty prone to
fears of all sorts so i'm wondering
is that the case first from your
research that americans
are more prone to this
and if so why do you think that's the
case
well i think that americans are not
necessarily more prone to conspiracy
theories in general
there are psychologists who believe that
conspiracy theories are really part of
the human condition because
when traumatic things happen it's a
human
quality to want to believe that there
was some reason for it that random
events don't just happen and in
particular that
there's a resistance to believing the
bad things happen to good people and so
when traumatic things happen and bad
things happen to good people it is sort
of a human response to say well let's
look for a reason and it's more
psychologically comforting to believe
that there's a conspiracy than simply to
think that there are these random
horrible things that happen in the world
and you have no control over them so
so there is this general um
psychological element to this this is
common throughout all cultures and times
i believe though that the conspiracy
theories about government as opposed to
jews catholics masons are more common in
20th and 21st century america because
first of all there's this
anti-government impulse throughout
american history a hostility to
centralized government and also because
in the 20th century the us government
does get a lot more powerful it does get
secret powers and secret agents it does
start spying on americans in the cold
war in particular it does start carrying
out conspiracies the cia does for
example conspire to kill foreign leaders
and so as a result
you have more theories about secret
government agents and secret government
conspiracies in the united states than
you do in cultures that have
less hostility to government and have a
government that is more open okay let's
unpack a few there's a lot in there okay
first off why
are americans so
anti-central government government
where's all that come from
oh there's a lot of a lot of historical
work on that but it really goes back to
the 18th century and um a fear of uh the
the british crown in the in the colonies
in a belief that um if you have too much
power in the central government then um
the the people in america have less
power but it's really shall we say
lingered i mean it's still quite common
so it's just sort of in our dna our
cultural dna yeah that's what some
people think right yeah and what about
the personality part you talked about
psychological theories so on
i know you're not a psychologist but in
your analysis of many of these examples
does there seem to be a personality type
or a couple personality types that are
more prone to believing in these
theories well certainly there's a
political type and that political
scientists have have analyzed this and
looked at data and say that people on uh
the extremes of the political express
the political spectrum are most inclined
to believe conspiracy theories so those
on the extreme right and those on the
extreme left now in in countries that
have a great deal of consensus about
their politics
like say sweden there are fewer
conspiracy theories
but in countries that are polarized you
get more conspiracy theories so in the
united states you have this this
interesting phenomenon where you have
people on the on the left and on the
right who don't agree about anything
else but they agree that their
government is conspiring against them
and some people call this fusion
paranoias like you have a spectrum and
it actually bends and people on the left
and the right meet in their their fear
of the government
and
in that regard it seems to me that your
analysis really departs from richard
hofstadter's analysis in the uh it was
called the paranoid style in american
politics right
which really is
takes much goes much farther down the
personality path
yes it does um hofstetter wrote his book
in the 1960s and it was a it's a really
brilliant book in which he argued that
conspiracy theories are a current
feature in american politics and he
located these conspiracy theories on the
fringes rather than in the center of
american life and he believed that um
americans had this uh not that they were
more prone to conspiracy theories but
that they were they did have this
paranoid style uh in their politics and
he was very interested in mccarthyism
very affected by it obviously he's
writing right after the mccarthy period
so he wanted to understand that and he
mainly saw this paranoia as a right-wing
phenomenon and as an irrational
phenomenon and he he saw it as a disease
and he asked the question why are
americans so paranoid and it is a really
useful question
but
i'm a historian of government secrecy
and i began my research in the 1990s and
it seemed to me
that
in my own research i saw a lot of
examples of real government conspiracies
and so i wanted to push hofstetter's
question further
and look at how things had changed since
the 1960s and how real government
conspiracies and the revelations of real
government conspiracies have influenced
conspiracy theories about the government
because you know in the 1960s it wasn't
so
um
it was logical for hofstede hofstetter
to put americans on the couch and say
why are they so crazy but after
watergate you know and after uh the
revelations that i looked at in my first
book about the cia and the fbi in the
early cold war
it was not so irrational perhaps for
americans to believe in conspiracy
theories about their government so i
wanted to look at what's the
relationship here and can we update this
uh in light of recent events and how
much do you think that
it's also
not only a change in what is happening
out there you know in in the world that
there really are these con these
government conspiracies which i want to
return to later also but but also that
that um you know
fashions change for lack of a better
word in academic analysis right and
intellectual analysis
you know you probably wouldn't have a
very popular analysis within the academy
if you took you know a freudian approach
these days
so you know how much how much and i
don't mean that as a criticism of the of
the fashions and the movements but
how much do you think your work is
influenced by those kinds of changes and
how we now talk about these things
oh definitely i think that i am a
product of my training and nobody writes
books you know
like hofstetter anymore and you know to
some degree that's that's not so great
because we tend to uh now be a lot more
specialized and we demand a lot more
footnotes and we don't make grand
statements about you know this is the
american style
so he was very much a product of his era
that way
i think what most influenced me as a
scholar is i studied at i started out
studying
the investigations of the cia and fbi
after watergate the so-called church
committee investigations
and
after i published that book in 1996
a lot of people started contacting me
with stories about they were very this
was a an academic press book it was my
dissertation yet i got a lot of feedback
from people around the country who were
very engaged with the subject who
believed they were the victims of
government conspiracies and sometimes it
was very difficult
to look at their stories and tell if
they were
you know needed medication or if they
really had been spied on by the fbi and
so i became very interested in sort of
figuring out this relationship
i know the feeling i did a study in a
psychiatric hospital
uh at one point in my career and there
was a patient who was saying that um
the mob was out together and it turned
out they were out together you know so
that does happen but so then in your
research
how do you sort out
which is which you know when you when
you get those kinds of reports now
obviously those that come in the mail or
one thing
but you know when you're working with
the documents right when you're working
in archives
there's also a lot of that kind of
material in fact from those same sorts
of sources right in a lot of these
archives of people telling their their
their stories
to one person or another who's recorded
them so how do you sort those out when
you're kind of you know working with the
data
well sometimes it's quite difficult
and
what i'm interested in is not so much
proving or disproving these conspiracy
theories but looking at why people
believe them and so
for example many of the people that i
study the con the people who spread a
lot of the conspiracy theories
believe that they were being followed by
the fbi and i can request their fbi file
and indeed they were being followed by
the fbi so there is this sort of
dynamic relationship
um
but um
i i'm not so much interested in figuring
out okay was this person can i find the
secret government file that proves that
this person was a victim of cia drug
testing as i am looking at okay what was
the cia drug testing program and so how
was it revealed
why would some americans believe that
they were victims of it
okay let's talk about that more broadly
how are these conspiracy theories
promoted and sold how does it
how do they catch on you know what why
do some catch on and not others you know
what have you do you have a sense of
what the difference is you know i mean
some of these that you talk about
are became
widely popular i mean we've already
talked about a couple of those and and
then others don't so what what
differentiates and how how are they
promoted
well i they're promoted by people who
want to either sell more books or to
sell their ideas so there are certainly
ideological or economic interests behind
many of these these theories
they they catch on if they happen to
really
well if they
come out of a period in u.s history
where there are government conspiracies
and there are cover-ups so that people
have a reason to suspect the government
and they say well if the government was
up to
we know that the government was was
conspiring here who's to say it's not
conspiring uh in this other area
and so um
the political context has to be right
also of course traumatic events tend to
inspire conspiracy theories pearl harbor
jfk 911 and there's also a generational
sort of cycle here where people get very
interested in a conspiracy theory about
an event that they live through and they
remember and then as those people age
and ultimately die that conspiracy
theory becomes um you know less popular
or even less known about
there's also though a a kind of
opportunistic element that has to do
with not the narrative anymore not the
story and or the speakers but imagery
right i mean i'm thinking about the 911
conspiracy theories you know these vivid
images that you see if you go to one of
these conspiracy websites of the
buildings falling and then of course
they add a narrative to that you know or
the rescue workers running away and it's
very scary very dramatic and then some
of the other conspiracy theories that
were widely believed there was also very
vivid imagery right
right well the two main examples here
would be 911 and also jfk with jfk the
the zapruder film um and you know some
uh cultural theorists have analyzed the
zapruder film as sort of a form of
almost pornography you know it's a it
was initially um suppressed by the
government so it's it's withheld from
public view and then um you know it's
really horrible uh violence yet some
people want to watch it over and over
and over again and it's the the same
with um the 9 11 theories and that you
have the very vivid imagery that um
attracts people to the subject
but in the case of 911 uh
the the images were not withheld at all
right right they were very much out
there and readily available so how did
the conspiracy theorists
sort of make them work to their
advantage
well um with both the supruder film and
the 911 clips what they do in the
documentaries is
show the clips over and over again and
then suggest alternative ways to
interpret them
so that say for example you know you see
the head snap uh in the zapruder film
and so that they say see this proves
that the bullet could not have come from
that direction or with 9 11 they they
point to little um
squirts of of
smoke coming out of the buildings and so
they say
that that did not happen the way the
government told us
and isn't that commonly what's done in
conspiracy conspiracy theories whether
with images or words or particular
incidents that it's about
contextualizing them in a different way
right about taking
an instant their set of incidents and
saying well yeah but look at this and
then that and that changes the whole way
we should see it right exactly
conspiracy theories are are ways of
telling stories um they're narratives of
events
and uh
many times in these events that i'm
looking at the government will suggest a
narrative and say this is what happened
and here's how we should interpret this
event and so the conspiracy theories are
often a way of citizens contesting that
and saying no we think that this event
should be interpreted in this way and
here's an alternative narrative of
events
and so it's really about who has the
ability
to tell that alternative account in a
way that it'll grab attention right so
not anyone can do it um although i guess
these days may be more so if you have if
you're if you can put together a
compelling internet site but certainly
until very recently you needed to be in
a position where you had a big megaphone
to do it didn't you yes although i i do
think that my research um
taught me that in the 1960s really this
becomes a much broader uh phenomenon and
that conspiracy theories really become
democratized
in the kennedy assassination in that
more and more people think that they can
solve this mystery and that they can
propose an alternative narrative
and before the internet it's difficult
for them to get out their theories but
nevertheless even in the 60s they do it
they they come up with a gorilla theater
place about the kennedy assassination or
they publish
alternative newspapers or also because
it's marketable they're able to get my
major publishers to to publish their
books and so even uh i'd say back in the
in the 60s when uh society is changing
in so many different ways that's another
way that it's changing
okay why don't we take a break and we'll
continue in a few moments
thanks
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with catherine olmstead
and barry glassner in a moment
here's a look at some of the upcoming
book fairs and festivals over the next
few months
next week enjoy fireside ghost stories
and family storytelling at night at the
10th annual cave run storytelling
festival in kentucky
as well as the 2009 fall for the book
festival in fairfax virginia
then the sonoma county book festival
puts on a program of art music
performances and panels in northern
california
at the end of september the baltimore
book festival hosts a weekend of
workshops author talks and literary
events
from the national mall in washington d.c
book tv brings you live coverage of the
2009 national book festival
in may next month the bangor book
festival welcomes best-selling author
douglas preston to give their opening
keynote address
fiction authors gather in vermont for a
weekend of literary discussions at the
brattleboro book festival
and the south dakota book festival
presents programs on medicine and health
literature as well as native american
history and culture
please let us know about book fairs and
festivals in your area and we'll add
them to our list
email us at book tv at c-span.org
afterwards with catherine olmstead and
barry glassner continues
in my own work on the culture of fear
i've been struck a lot by how it is that
the old adage follow the money
really explains things except i would
revise it a little i would say follow
the career ambitions
you know so a lot of these scares and
are spread by people who are trying to
advance their careers you know either by
running for office you know and if if as
a politician
you say something scary about what will
happen if the other person wins or about
the other person
advocacy groups do this to raise money
and i was struck in your analysis that
conspiracy theories
are often spread by people who have very
specific things to gain
so i wonder if you could talk about that
a little bit
yes well i think there it's a little of
both in that there there definitely are
sometimes people who spread the
conspiracy theories because they have
something to gain um there are the
people who know that if they publish a
book on uh jfk with you know his picture
with a target
around it that they're gonna make a lot
of money and so they don't care so much
about about researching the truth
and so there are a lot of people for
example who have claimed to be the
second or third or fourth gunman in the
jfk assassination there's a whole long
list of them
so there are people who realize oh if i
spread this conspiracy theory i can
personally make money i think in in what
i've discovered though more often
it's uh people in power politicians
public officials who think well if i
spread this conspiracy theory then i can
uh gain more power and the classic
example of this would be would be
senator joe mccarthy who uh said that
there were hundreds of um card-carrying
communists in the state department at
the very moment that he was talking and
the secretary of state knew the names of
all of these people and yet was still
allowing them to to to work and so uh he
was essentially charging that there that
the american government was
being controlled secretly by the soviet
union now he knew that this was not true
and yet he deliberately used these
exaggerated claims and implied that the
secretary of defense and the secretary
of state themselves were communist
agents because it helped his own
personal agenda he could regain power
he could get reelected and his his party
could come back into power and you
certainly have cases like that there are
also cases
where
presidents would spin conspiracy
theories because that helps their agenda
because if the germans or the communists
or the terrorists are out to get us then
you give the government you see more
power to the government to protect you
and so there's certainly an agenda that
way but there's also i think in
conspiracy theories
a lot of times when uh people believe
that genuinely their work is going to uh
protect america and so it's more
complicated than saying it's simply
selfish a selfish economic desire or
selfish desire for power
and here i would give the example of j
edgar hoover
the chief of the fbi for 50 years in
that
hoover clearly believed that if he
promoted the domestic communist threat
to the united states that the fbi would
get more resources and he would get more
power yet at the same time i think he
really believed that the united states
was in danger from domestic communists
so it all sort of worked for him um and
i think
um many of the alternative conspiracy
theorists who charge that the government
is is covering up or involved in some
conspiracy um
genuinely believe that and they think
that it's their public duty their civic
duty as americans to expose this
conspiracy so it can be complicated it
isn't so much a matter of just people
manipulating the public to sell books
let me pick up on several aspects of
that because
your answer goes to something else i
found fascinating the book and that is
kind of tension between the amateurs and
the experts
and both of them fit in some of the
categories you just talked about the
amateurs tend to be very passionate
either because they think the truth is
being hidden and it shouldn't be or
often for what the reason you said you
know they think that it's really crucial
to to america
or the world to get to get to the
reality of this and they're just going
to go do it whatever the way they can
and one thing i thought was
was really kind of neat is that
sometimes what you document
is
what i suspect is the most common
pattern that the amateurs come up with
the conspiracy conspiracy theories that
then the experts refute
um but in some cases it's not like that
and one that sticks in my mind from your
book was a 1979 i think it was roughly
right in there that there was a
publication of a girly magazine called
gallery and they included an insert of
what was supposed to be a recording from
the kennedy assassination from dealey
plaza of the shots fired and the courts
had been all this debate and commissions
and so forth about how many shots and
what do we make of it from from this
recording and i guess many many hours
many many experts looking at and
listening to this recording and
analyzing it and so some rock musician
somewhere in the midwest right
buys this
issue of this magazine and listens to
this thing for three or four months over
and over again and finally he hears
another voice
that clearly
indicated that it hadn't in fact the
recording hadn't actually happened been
made at the time
of the of the shooting but rather later
which then
clarified the the whole reality of the
recording and kind of
here it was an amateur using stuff
using
a material product that amateurs had
been using to refute the conspiracy
theory
yes and that's what's so interesting i
think particularly about the kennedy
assassination is that there are people
on all sides who decide that they can
solve the assassination if and um they
they get all kinds of information in
order to to help them and this is
different because um
say earlier conspiracy theories like the
anti-communist conspiracy theories you
didn't have ordinary americans going to
washington dc and saying i'm going to
find alger his typewriter
they they turned that over to the
experts and they they listened when the
politicians or the journalists told them
the conspiracy theories but they didn't
say i'm gonna prove this myself what's
different in the kennedy assassination
is you have ordinary americans deciding
okay i can solve this mystery
and so they go down to dallas themselves
and they they go and they find
eyewitnesses and what are called ear
witnesses people who heard the shots and
they interview them and um they they
they walk off um oswald's route to see
if the fbi was telling the truth about
how long it took him to get from point a
to point b
they send four maps of the dallas sewer
system so they can figure out if
somebody was hiding in a storm drain
they study the pictures of the
assassination to see if there are a
gunman hiding in the in the shadows or
the bushes and so you have all of these
ordinary americans saying i can solve
this crime
and part in the 60s part of what
the kennedy assassination movement is
about is people saying i don't trust the
government and also i don't trust the
scientific experts who are telling me
these things
i'm going to have my son stand in the
backyard holding a rifle and i'm going
to take a picture of him and see where
the shadow falls in order to figure out
uh if this picture of oswald with a
rifle has been faked or not you know i'm
going to solve this myself now
ironically many much of the time the
source material that they use to prove
that the government's in a conspiracy is
government material you know they get
government documents their primary
source material is the government
commission report on the kennedy
assassination which they study endlessly
um in in the case of the the 1979 um
uh what was called the dictabelt this
audio recording or supposed audio
recording of the assassination you have
um this ordinary citizen uh deciding he
can prove it and deciding that in fact
there was not a conspiracy
and he was right and he was right yeah
right and but then it's also the case
that it took experts
to confirm that he was right right and
that's the part i left out intentionally
when i asked you the question that way
right but that that's what followed up
right but then um
you know as i'm reading your analysis
here
the um amateurs who sometimes develop
the theories or in laurie jump on them
uh
sometimes they play a really beneficial
role
beyond the sort we just talked about
which was is not very common i think you
know of of actually getting to the truth
of the of a particular aspect but more
generally right because they open the
matter up so that at a minimum
uh there's the kind of investigation
that should go on
to find out what really happened and
more than that they hope they suggest
that hiding information isn't going to
work particularly well that they're
always all of us amateurs out there
they're going to
get on you for doing that if you're if
you're a government official who does it
but then when you weigh the pros and the
cons the advantages and disadvantages
of the amateurs work and of of
conspiracy theorizing in general you
come out pretty strongly
in the negative that the the that the
costs outweigh the benefits right
well i think yes
i think there are costs and benefits um
it's important to remember that it isn't
just amateurs though who are doing this
theorizing that there are government
officials who spread conspiracy theories
and so uh and there are there are some
benefits that i should perhaps point out
to start with with um
the amateur conspiracy theories the
people who are making these charges
against the government
in that they can force information to
come out
so for example after oliver stone's 1991
movie jfk
congress passed and the president signed
an act that required the
declassification of a lot of documents
about the kennedy assassination and not
just about the murder itself but about
kennedy's secret foreign policy so
historians know a lot more about
kennedy's foreign policy as a result of
that movie as a result of that
conspiracy theory than they would
otherwise and so as a historian i always
have an interest in more information
more documents and so i appreciate it
when conspiracy theorists you know force
this information to come out
on the other hand conspiracy theories of
course teach people to to think in terms
of black and white and
make the discourse more polarized
and the
conspiracy theories
about the government can also engender
so much distrust that it's impossible
for
us to do anything collectively as a
society which means it's hard to address
major problems
but let's let's stay with the candy
assassination for a minute and i have to
confess that i want to do that partly
because i was an amateur
never actually conspiracy theorists but
i just found the whole thing fascinating
um and i fell into what i think was very
common with that one
and that is it just seems so implausible
that this guy could have done this
from that place that angle that way you
know
it just didn't
given all that happened in the way it
happened just didn't seem like it was
really possible
and i've known some people who were
major researchers of right kennedy
assassination
um and of the conspiracy theories
so
i think it's true what you're saying
that we get into these and
for the reasons you say and as a
sociologist i would add another big one
that it's just when there are monumental
events
um that that really do change the course
of history and change the society we
want there to be a monumental
conspiracy behind it or something
monumental behind it not just this guy
who is up
you know in this book depository and
knew how to do this well enough and got
lucky enough that it worked
um so so i think that that's all that's
all true
but at the same time
you know it feels a little creepy to me
to think that well have we really
settled some of these
right just because um you know we've had
all these commissions and the experts
have ruled then they rule again
so how i guess the question i'm asking
with just let's stick with the kennedy
assassination for a minute because i do
think as you've said yourself that it's
different in certain ways than some of
the others
um
will it ever be settled what would
really settle it
you know
that's a really good question um it's
difficult to know
because
uh lyndon johnson right after the
kennedy murder decided
that uh there were certain things about
the murder that the american people
could not know
lyndon johnson himself was a conspiracy
theorist
and that he believed that he told
several people that he thought fidel
castro
probably killed president kennedy and he
believed that castro did this in
retaliation
because kennedy cia was plotting to kill
castro
and so johnson himself believed in a
conspiracy yet he set up this commission
to reassure the american public that
there was no conspiracy
now why did he do that well because
johnson based his conspiracy theory on
not because he was had the paranoid
style but because he had secret
information he knew about the plots
against fidel castro and so
he knew that the cia had for example
been cooperating with anti-castro cubans
and with mobsters who were angry with
castro because he had kicked them out of
of um havana
he knew that castro had been targeted by
the cia and so he thought that this
opened up possibilities
of all kinds of conspiracies in the
kennedy murder but johnson did not want
the castro plots to come out because
this would have been very embarrassing
for the united states and also because
he thought that it could lead to nuclear
war
that uh if
it turned out that castro killed kennedy
then he would be forced to invade cuba
and then this could lead to world war
iii which by the 1960s both sides have
nuclear missiles it could mean the end
of the world in fact he recorded a lot
of his conversations in the week after
the kennedy murder in which he's talking
to various people about setting up this
commission and he's talking about the
dangers of these conspiracy theories and
he says you know uh it could lead to
nuclear war they could kill 39 million
americans in an hour and he keeps using
that he was obviously briefed on this 39
million very specific stuck in his mind
so johnson for all of these reasons
decides we can't go down certain paths
of evidence
in this murder because they might lead
to places that could be very
embarrassing very damaging to america
and you know even perhaps lead to the
end of the world so he says okay we're
going to set up this commission the
fbi's already got the story we're going
to reassure everyone that the crime has
been solved
um
even as he personally does not believe
this
so it's very complicated uh and then
when people when ordinary people start
learning about the castro plots and the
use of the mafia they start coming up
with all kinds of different conspiracy
theories and this is what the church
committee in 1975 had this big
investigation that revealed all of these
assassination plots against castro that
then created this big explosion of
conspiracy theories about kennedy that
led to the formation of the house
committee the house of representatives
committee to investigate so you started
getting all of this information in the
70s but by then of course a lot of the
trails have gone cold and a lot of the
people have died
and some of the people are
die
uh violently during the hearings which
of course feeds the the conspiracy
theories a couple of the mobsters get
killed uh and so um as a result of all
of this it's it's one of those that i
think it's very hard to say oh well we
know exactly what happened
nevertheless
i am most convinced by the lone gunman
theory because as unlikely as it sounds
it's hard to put together another theory
that i think works as well it fits as
much evidence but i'm certainly
an agnostic audit and i would not be
surprised if someday something comes up
that that convinces me otherwise but i i
would be really surprised if something
new comes out because there were all
these investigations and so many people
so much uh evidence um you know
disappeared so so many trails were not
followed and so many people have died
since then it's it's hard to imagine
that you know there will be some day
when we can say okay now we know exactly
what happened
and do we know what the two presidents
we've talked about in this regard
believed do we know what johnson
believed late in his life and and we we
you mentioned also clinton
when he was elected right wondered this
this that was a big question for him do
we know where where
johnson was and where clinton is on on
the conclusion to
to who killed jfk well i think johnson
was was quite
quite definite that he thought castro
did it too
to his dying day as far as we know yeah
yeah um he told several people this um
you know of course johnson was not a
great fan of john kennedy so i think you
know there was maybe something going on
with him where he thought
uh well in a way it was kennedy got what
he was coming to him because he planned
these plots so that could have been
going on as opposed to him knowing for
sure it was simply his theory
clinton i don't know obviously he he had
a lot of questions when he was elected
and of course he can write us and let us
know what he concluded
because he's still around but um
let's go go
back just a little bit to one that we
really haven't talked much about and
that's the watergate scandal
and you know
nixon famously excused um you know the
behavior of his administration himself
the break breakdown the illegal wiretaps
and so forth by saying that he was far
from the first president to uh you know
engage in in conspiracies
um so i guess my first question about
that is was that a true statement
well he was not the first president to
engage in conspiracies no but i think
that he engaged in them in them on a
scale
that was really uh unprecedented
and uh what was particularly nefarious
about his approach was that he decided
to discredit
all of his predecessors particularly his
his uh democratic predecessors in order
to exonerate himself so that he told the
plumbers uh he told howard hunt go look
in the national archives and find
evidence um that that um
that roosevelt knew about pearl harbor
in advance
that john kennedy ordered the
assassination of diem of
south vietnam
uh that
that these presidents um
actually engaged in all of these
conspiracies so that then the american
people
will be disgusted and then they will
also say oh okay well then what nixon
did was no big deal
so i think it's it's really um
very
selfish selfish and self interested on
his part to do this now uh
the people that he sent into the
archives to try and find this
information came back and said you know
it's like spooning out the ocean you
know there's all these documents
it's not like there's some
dwarf you unlock and you find the secret
to pearl harbor uh it's much more
complicated than that but i think it's
very interesting that that even
presidents like nixon like clinton later
thought that there was some vault
where all government secrets were
contained but as you said nixon did this
to protect him to try to protect himself
and to put his
commissions and into some kind of larger
perspective historical perspective but
isn't the case that his those actions
did in fact reveal
some conspiratorial activities in the
past
or at least revealed to the public
because they were talked about then
that hadn't been quite as visible
well he
he wanted to revisit some conspiracy
theories that were out there for example
pearl harbor and roosevelt and then he
wanted to leak
that information to
people or in this case in the pearl
harbor case to newspapers that he knew
would want that information so he was
being very cynical and saying i want to
get these old theories and then breathe
new life into them but he couldn't find
any new evidence for them it was just
really the cynical enterprise on on his
part to try and create so much distrust
in the government that this would help
him personally to survive
now he personally believed i mean he
conspired a lot and he believed that
everyone else conspired a lot but really
he was in a class by himself
okay that was that was the next question
i was going to ask you he really was
unique in that regard right as far as we
know as far as we know yes
and he recorded everything too i mean
johnson recorded a lot of his
conversations so that you can listen uh
to for example many of the phone
conversations he made he had in the uh
weeks after the kennedy assassination so
that you can understand uh you know his
own views
but nixon um recorded not just the the
phone but also the conversations he was
having in the in the oval office and and
they do reveal that he genuinely
believed that everyone was involved in a
conspiracy that everyone was conspiring
against him and so it was you know only
natural for him to conspire against them
um
but certainly his paranoia
his level of paranoia was was unique
it certainly seems that way so it's good
to have it confirmed by an african
historian who's researched it
uh let me bring us up to the present
conspiracy theory of the moment
uh 9 11.
uh
is is this in your view is 911 the new
jfk assassination for conspiracy folks
because what really has struck me about
this and and this i have to hasten to
say as a sociologist is not based on
good data
but it certainly looks to me like it's
mostly younger people
who believe conspiracy theories about 9
11 or certainly who promote them
actively and tell me if i'm wrong
um but that also strikes me is that
that's what was the case with the was
also the case with the kennedy
assassination it was that generation of
people who kind of came of age when that
happened or were maybe a little younger
in the case of jfk because you know
you were called out of school when it
happened and even if you're fairly young
you remember it but you know that
basically the generation for whom it was
a real monumental event
is really what draws the the folks who
who believe in the conspiracy theory in
both cases yes i think that's definitely
true uh the polls show that about a
third of americans uh
across all ages believe that the bush
administration was involved in 911
either knew about it in advance and
decided not to stop it or actually was
involved in planning and executing the
event and those numbers go way up when
you look
at age and that
a majority of americans aged 18 to 29
believe these theories so this could
mean
that these theories become more popular
over time um there's certainly a
generational aspect though to conspiracy
theories about the government in that uh
you know it's common when you're younger
to question authority and to see
a theory that's questioning authority is
is somehow you know cooler and and um
uh
more compelling than
uh someone saying no no no the
government would never do that sort of
thing
um but uh so there is that also i think
that um 911 shares with the kennedy
assassination and with pearl harbor
um this sense for the people who lived
through it that the world really changed
and so they want to go back to that
event
and say all right this altered my
universe
and so
i want to thoroughly understand it
and to
see this
as a completely random event or an event
that the united states
uh could not stop
is is very threatening and so they want
to make more sense of it now when people
went back and looked at the the kennedy
assassination they saw that as a turning
point in the 60s
when uh they believed that you know in
retrospect that everything was going
great up to then and then after that you
get
the um
you get more american involvement in
vietnam and you get all of the problems
of the 60s you get race riots you get
all of the protests against the war and
you get polarization and so they say
that was the moment that american
democracy died and i think for
some young americans who lived through
911 they have a similar perspective that
this was the moment
when uh a country that had been
prosperous and on the right track
somehow went off the rails so they want
to look back to that event and make
sense of it that's also compounded isn't
it by what we were constantly told after
9 11
that i still find appalling
everything changed on 9 11. remember i
mean we were told that for a long time
by many many people many many different
walks of life and i think that leads to
this kind of concern too if everything
changed it couldn't just be
you know this group of whatever you know
somewhere between what a a dozen and a
few dozen people who who put it together
right it has it couldn't be i mean that
that's the notion that that kind of
makes the conspiracy theory seem viable
right right with the phrase arabs and
caves is used a lot that they couldn't
have done this you know in pearl harbor
it was similar and people would say oh
the japanese couldn't have done this we
must have done it to ourselves
and so you're right all the rhetoric
about after 9 11 about oh everything's
everything's changed uh led to the sense
of of of crisis and desire to make sense
of all of the change now also of course
we must say that the bush administration
promoted its own conspiracy theory about
9 11 that iraq was somehow involved
and this i think really
led people to look for broader
explanations
and so when the 911 commission proved
that iraq was not involved in 911 this
led people to say okay well that proves
that the government was lying about that
particular conspiracy theory but is
there another conspiracy theory that
makes sense and that perhaps even
includes the official conspiracy
theorists themselves
well that goes to the larger question
that maybe maybe we can end with which
is i wanted to ask you you know as i was
reading the book and even more as i'm
listening to you today
i keep getting my mind that old bumper
sticker you know just because you're
paranoid doesn't mean they're not out to
get you and and you know i remember um
back in the 70s i guess it was um that
when when people friend of mine on the
left would say that um it turned out
they were right you know there was
cointelpro right the fbi was trying i
guess a little earlier but the fbi was
trying to systematically harass
was systematically harassing dr martin
luther king jr
um and so you know given those and the
more recent examples we just talked
about
how is a person
an average person to make the
distinction how are we supposed to know
right are the is the government really
out to get us are they really creating
conspiracies um or is this just um
another
you know another wrong explanation
well i always tell my students that it's
hard work you know it's hard work being
a citizen of a democracy you have to
read a lot you have to keep yourself
informed you have to question authority
you also have to question the conspiracy
theorists who are out of power you know
you have have government officials
telling you things you also have people
out of power alternative conspiracy
theories you need to demand
explanations and not just say oh that
sounds right or i trust that person or
this person or i distrust that person or
this person you really have to
investigate you really need to to make
use of your resources of the media and
all the information that's available to
us uh in this information age and and
make your own decisions
and is there anything that you can point
to that distinguishes a real government
conspiracy from one that is imagined or
maybe there's no way to do that except
for all that kind of investigation
evidence that's the only thing you know
you have
i mean what was watergate right there
was a conspiracy theory
among say reporters at the washington
post that the president was involved in
this conspiracy and then the tapes came
out and proved that it was a real
conspiracy iran contra you know
conspiracy theory until the evidence
comes out real conspiracy um
other conspiracies uh you know we don't
have the evidence yet and that doesn't
mean always that they didn't happen but
it doesn't mean that we need to demand
the evidence and keep looking for it
great well thank you very much it's been
wonderful thanks a lot thank you
elizabeth bracket correspondent for